we're about to go on our first project
mini adventure and it's dog sledding
thank you guys for voting because I'm so
excited to do this there's no dogs
attached but soon there will be
high-five
okay so we just got back from dog
sledding it was so awesome these dogs
are just like the cutest little things
ever so let us know what you guys want
to see us do tomorrow either go to the
Blue Lagoon or do deep-sea extreme
fishing here's our hashtags tweet them
to us to make your vote and yeah that's
all I got to do see you guys later
isn't that right could be you don't go I
think you just fell asleep in my hands
no you did it I'm gonna move over a
little okay okay